hi everybody welcome to another link
gathering just waiting for Steve to join
us hang on a second I can resend the
link somehow thanks very much Paul and
Chris for volunteering to share your
link story with us share how you use
link feel free to share your screen if
you like there's a share screen option
at the bottom of the page click on it
and choose the window that you want to
share or feel free not to share it's up
to you of course let us know how you use
link how much you've enjoyed how long
you can use it maybe start by
introducing yourself of course Oh
someone is already sharing which means
it must mean Chris you want to start I'm
not sure I can hear you Chris is your
microphone my audio settings might need
to be can you hear me now oh yeah yeah I
can hear you no well I don't you know I
guess hopefully everybody's keeping well
here as we continue to stay home and
look forward to hearing from from our
guest today Chris maybe yeah with up
please introduce yourself and then maybe
share a bit about about using how you
link okay yo my name is Chris Chris
Young and I'm a retired doctor I retired
a year ago and faculty just briefly
explained my language journey and how
Linc fits into it if that's okay
with your permission yeah please please
do we're looking at your email right now
yeah I don't know if you want to want to
be showing something else but just to
let you know just close that I'm not
seeing you very well I'm pretty new to
to zoom but I'm learning it on the job
as it were that's good
anyway so yeah so I returned just over a
year ago and my wife sent me a link to
Lydia micawber's well-known TED talk
which I'm sure most of you know and to
cut a long story short I had to wait for
one of her academies and I said what
should I do in the meantime because I'd
learn French at school I thought I'd
resurrect that so they very helpful team
pointed me towards French podcasts
because I was focusing on French so the
first podcast I listened to was in
friend Hugo cotton which is very good
for intermediate listeners he speaks
relatively slowly and very clearly it's
a very good resource interesting topic
and does fast-forward to later in the
year when he interviewed Steve and
that's when I heard about link for the
first time so that was about six months
ago and shortly after that I started
listening to Steve's YouTube and all of
a sudden he was learning three languages
at once so I thought okay
I'll give it a go - and it was a bit mad
of course insane I think is your
expression on on the on the app hundreds
a day with three different languages
which is kind of taller as I think Steve
found so I cut that down to 50 and and
then later on we planned a fairly short
notice a trip to Rio so I started
learning Brazilian Portuguese as well so
that's four languages which was totally
insane but not saying same because they
are all Romance languages and so it was
you know relatively easy to fit them all
in and of course the resources are on
link you can look look at in various
different languages now like Steve's
language Odyssey and the mini stories
and so forth and just to expand a bit on
these Spanish resources that I've been
using again focused on intermediate
level and I look at one link of course
checking my notes here and unlimited
Spanish is a very good resource with
Oscar bait base mm-hmm nice topics
little smattering of grammar but that's
okay not too much and notes in Spanish
intermediate and they do beginners and
also advanced and I focused on
intermediate and they they use a formula
which seems to work very well I think in
these resources which is a conversation
between two people
one of which has to be a native speaker
so so I think that's a very good formula
mm-hmm and in Portuguese I started
looking at Portuguese three months
before we went on holiday and I found
Brazilian
odd class and Brazilian Portuguese
podcast and also using links resources
you know the many stories and so forth
and I must say I thought link was
brilliant because I was able to get past
what I would phrasebook Portuguese you
know where are the toilets two beers
please
you know and you want you want a bit
more than that when you go on holiday
mm-hmm and so so that's really what I
want to say and what what I what I do my
my daily use of link is I try to do 50
links a day in each of the four
languages and they're all Romance
languages so it'll fit in nicely and I
reviews like a long you know depends on
how things pan out you know I don't
always manage to do the fifty links
first thing in the morning but that's
the goal right and then I try to make
use of dead time during the day but I
would just add had something which I
think is pertinent to at the time as
we're living in now
and that is I don't listen to languages
when I'm outside because listening to
the birdsong and looking at blue sky is
actually very good for the well-being at
the moment so that's just a personal
thing and the other thing is of course
if you use too much for your dead time
you know your wife says you always
walking around with your earplugs in
every day so I guess that's about my
story okay great well thanks thanks very
much for sharing that's yeah great some
great resources there for our audience
who are studying those languages and uh
how long so how long have you been on on
link just under six months okay okay
great sure yeah no I just think the when
I was on that hundred links a day in
each of three languages unconnected
languages Persian Arabic and Turkish
that was a bit much but I maintain it
for quite a while and I think the idea
that you're forced to do something
that's almost like a it's like a
mechanical task you have to do it okay
you have to take out the garbage once a
week whatever is it's a it's a
mechanical task even if you aren't
particularly interested you've set
yourself that goal that kind of works
and it forces you into new material I
found though that with Persian and
Arabic being very difficult to read
because it takes so long that you used
to that script they was just too tough
but if you're doing for Romance
languages and you're forcing yourself to
do fifty links in each language that
means you're pushing yourself into new
content a lot of the vocabulary is gonna
be familiar just slightly look slightly
different in the other language I think
that's very doable and it just keeps you
going I think that's a really good thing
to do and the other question I had was
that you mentioned podcasts have you
listened to both Brazilian Portuguese
and podcast from Portugal or are you
strictly listening to
in Portuguese you know I've listened to
both because I have a comment for one of
your YouTube's Rash said it doesn't
really matter when you're a beginner
which I agree with I mean the Portuguese
from Portugal is more difficult to
understand but I think it's in any of
these languages where people get so fast
oh I don't want to listen to Spanish
from Spain or from Mexico it doesn't
really matter it's essentially the same
words and you may as well get used to
these different you know ways people
pronounce the language it only improves
the flexibility of your brain and at
some point if you want to focus in on
one and you focus in on one in order to
imitate that pronunciation but I always
recommend people shouldn't get too
fussed about whether this is québécois
French or French from France or whatever
just it's really good that's right if I
could chip in there again I came across
a restauranteur in South Africa from
from Madeira and so I tried out my
Brazilian Portuguese on I mean he
understood what I meant but he knew I
was talking Brazilian Portuguese and he
said next time you come I want you to
speak Angolan Portuguese and Madeira
Portuguese so maybe I won't do that but
it's it's fun the other thing I wanted
to chip in with was it's a very noticed
thing to do but I write down cognates
just as a digression you know pick up a
word in one language and I check the
others in the other language the
equivalent and this it's good fun it's
fun to do if you're in related languages
like the Polish and Ukrainian and
Russian and Jack and whatever it's
always fun variety is the spice of life
do what we like to do we have a question
from from the audience here my question
is can I do both a link and rosetta
stone mix to learn a language
well I mark has some experience with
with rose
I don't really so I always say they'll
do what you like to do and variety is
important if you're covering the same
material in two or three different ways
that's good you know and before we had a
link if I started to learn a language I
would buy two or three starter books so
I covered the same starter material in
two or three different books they're
only twenty thirty dollars each but I
have no idea about rosetta stone mark
you did to present us on for Japanese I
think yeah I mean I would say like you
say I mean you can if you're a beginner
then you can do a bit of rosetta stone
or some other beginner thing but you
know as soon as possible you kind of
want to get out of that stage and into
using real content like we do on link to
really kind of drive your growth and and
you know whatever the tool is most tools
that are out there really they really
only get you started so yeah if you'd
like rosetta stone go for it
it's not that it's not a bad thing to do
definitely use link with it so you get
input like which you don't get in most
other tools just don't get the volume of
input that you need like the listening
and the reading so hopefully that
answers that question
another question how do you maintain the
languages that you know and and feel
free at Chris and Paul to also chime in
if you have thoughts on any of these
questions maintaining issue always ask
me with so many languages and learning
new languages how do you maintain the
languages that you know so first of all
I don't worry about it
languages that I already know may slip
in the short run however my experience
is when I go back to them they quickly
recover to where they were and if
anything I end up further along than I
ever was so when I go to refresh my
language and like some of my weaker
languages if I have to you know
make a video in the language or
something and there's two strategies one
is if I'm pretty good at the language
I'll just read in the language get a
book in German listen to podcast in
Portuguese if I'm not so strong in the
language I'll go back to the many
stories to me the many stories it's like
you know how in in working out you have
core exercises the the theory being that
if you really work your core your abs
your back that gives you strength that
enables you to do well in whatever sport
you're gonna do like the core is
important to build up a strong core and
I think the many stories are like the
core so I go back to them because they
have the most common expressions the
most common verbs the most common
conjunctions and connecting words and
phrases and so to refresh I'll either
just do something in the language if I'm
fairly good at it or I'll go back to the
mini stories but I never do it in the
senses oh gee I might forget the
language or I'm slipping I don't worry
about it well if I've been away from the
language when I start up again I'm gonna
slip and I'm gonna stumble but very
quickly I'll be back to where I was and
and pretty soon I found that that this
absence maybe because I've been working
my brain to learn other languages if
anything makes me better in those
languages than I was before so it's just
not a concern of mine okay I see
Rodney's asking where are the many
stories you should just be able to
search in the library go to the library
tab and search for many stories or link
many stories but many stories should
should show you those stories there
typically are also in the lesson feed as
many users are using them and liking
them give something say Chris no I just
wanted to add to maintaining different
languages at once what I do is I focus
the listening on a different language
each day of the week which is a bit
random I mean I don't do in a strict
order whatever pops up on link then I
choose that language to focus my
listening on
so that's the way I handle four
different languages at once okay yeah
makes sense actually Chris can you stop
sharing your screen now okay okay so
who's me all along sorry that's all
right Paul maybe you yeah you'd like to
go next and yeah sure
so like when you've been using Lync for
the past like three four months so I'm
still a beginner I would say um but I'm
trying to share my screen but I think
it's gonna let me and when I very first
started using it I usually just gone to
the beginning uh spitting in the media
bed into the I came a bit in the library
when I was in there I found like a
couple of channels on YouTube so the
first one was espanol automatic oh and
you see Spanish which were just like 10
minute videos 10 20 minute videos such
as people speaking I found out to be
quite helpful one minute after I got
bored of them which was quite fast be
honest at watching Netflix like started
just download an episode to like I'll
trouble things in there and what I would
do is out maybe watch 15 20 minutes and
go the translation they're trying to
figure out the bits that I'd missed and
kind of try and try and figure out
what's what's going on in there after
that I kind of realize that there's a
lot more but you can cover a lot more
words by like listen to audiobooks so I
would listen to you audiobooks and read
at the same time so I would usually just
there find out what the Spanish
translation was to become another read
so if like everyone else I think how you
pause my favorite book so I started
reading Harry Potter and I've read so it
down Brahmas books as well and usually I
just find if you go to google and you
type in the book that you want and just
put PDF at the end
it usually just comes up with the first
landing people just import the pic and a
link but yeah I'm just missing the audio
because I think the audio books help
quite a bit
yeah I found like a read to get good
audio you probably there is them some
like on YouTube but usually get away
halfway through and you realize that the
other half isn't there so just got
audible now so I just like by the books
inaudible and then listen and read it at
the same time yeah that's great I think
I I have to agree with you that YouTube
videos and and Netflix are they're fun
for sure but they that the word density
that you get in with books audiobooks
and ebooks it's just in terms of for
link when you start progressing you end
up I end up feeling like I wish I could
find
alright well I want to find good books
and having a tough time with that and
Japanese right now because it seems they
make it very hard to get Japanese books
online but I know when I was doing
Italian it was great I got lots of books
to choose from and I did the same had
audible so I whatever audiobooks were
available in Italian on audible those
are the books I would then go try and
find there's an Italian audiobooks store
that I would buy them from but it's or
does that search that's a good idea to
although we don't we can't recommend we
break them and buying them but but yeah
that's a great way for sure to to use
link I mean you import a book and you've
got content for weeks yeah I mean on
that sure just to again agree with what
both of you are saying
movies are fun movies are stimulating I
remember when I started into Russian I
saw some Russian movies for the Soviet
movies are really good
quality and there were some wonderful
movies about the 19th century and you
know you get all excited it's very it's
it's very you know stimulating but it's
hard to learn from them and you have to
sit there in front of the screen right
and and the word density in books is so
much higher and especially if the script
isn't an obstacle but even even the
Cyrillic alphabet is not a big problem
but with with Persian and Arabic is just
that much more difficult but like polish
I found there's a website called audio
tech ax T audio te ka and it has audio
books in Polish and Czech and stuff and
then there's websites where you can get
the e-book and I don't mind paying for
the audiobook or the e-book because as
Mark says you got it for a month you
know because it takes a long time to go
through a book but when you do it like I
remember I knew this person who was a
Swedish wife of one of my business
associates and she loved French and she
traveled to France and I once gave her
an audio book in French some novel and
she said oh it's too difficult I can't
understand it I think to really get your
comprehension up you should set yourself
a goal at some point I'm gonna listen to
an audio book a novel but of course it's
gonna be difficult so you need to get
the e-book so you can work your way
through it and get the words and phrases
but it's a tremendous achievement and
and it's a tremendous experience to
listen to an audiobook in the language
you're learning that's kind of like a
major milestone when you achieve that so
I think audiobooks and ebooks are are
more powerful really and I guess how
quickly you can go there depends on how
similar the language is to a language
you know how familiar the writing system
is but audiobooks and ebooks are good
value it unfortunately and I can't
remember what the term is but a lot of
the ebooks are protected by whatever it
is and you can't import them into link
even if you've paid for them and I find
that extremely annoying
that's the DRM DRM yeah yeah and there
are ways to remove it and I think it's
fine to remove it you're using it for
your own personal use but it's still not
that easy I think Kindle can be really
difficult to remove the DRM for
yeah it's just an it's just another
obstacle so it prevents people from
doing it like as you say even if you buy
the e-book it's hard to get it isn't
link working on a DRM removal system
that we can sell well we would love at
some point to have some some arrangement
with publishers so that we could
actually have integrated audiobooks and
keep audio ebooks I guess available
through link I mean that would make it
way easier for everybody but though the
whole book world seems very convoluted
'men the way it manages rights and I
don't know exactly how the best way we
would tackle that is but someday for
sure we'd like to do that because books
are great content especially to really
kind of you one book and can can add you
know 5,000 known words I find like it
once you get going it really drives
vocabulary growth you know it's if I
could interject to I think it's very
unfortunate so many people want to learn
languages and so then you have teachers
or language experts writing yet another
grammar book on Spanish yet another you
know whatever system
if only audiobooks and ebooks were
readily available okay you got to pay
for it but then you've got it you can
import you can do what you want with it
and similarly with podcasts there are so
many podcasts out there like those
podcasts out of Portugal that are really
very good like hours and hours of
podcasts no transcripts all my Persian
and Arabic podcasts no transcripts
somehow and then and then like here in
Canada we have our national broadcasters
Canadian Broadcasting Corporation Radio
Canada who are apparently investing
millions of dollars to develop some kind
of language teaching website where there
will be comprehension questions and all
kinds of useless stuff like that if they
would just provide transcripts for all
their programming you know and so
there's programming in English
programming in French their stuff and
then on news on history on cooking on
sports you name it people could go to
not just CBC in Canada but BBC and
Britain or whatever might be in other
countries and they would
access to all this stuff to learn that
would be the biggest contribution any of
these podcasters and broadcasters could
make to the world of language learning
don't come up with in another system
another grammar book and all this other
useless stuff just give us content that
can be mined add link or on other sites
but where you can save words and phrases
you can work your way through these
things where you always have the
transcript for the audio you have the
audio for the text that's what the world
of language learning needs in my opinion
someday we'll get there it can chip in
again there because I had I had an idea
I often get ideas these days it's
generally held that language classes are
a waste of time and I sort of agree with
that from my own experience you know you
pay a lot of money and you go to the
course and you're bored with a grammar
after a short time and then half the
class leave and then the class folds up
completely but the point of the story is
that if people want to learn a language
they usually sign up to a class first
and my contention is the problem is the
way the language class is run in other
words if the content is engaging and
entertaining then people stick with it
and if you use the same principles that
we all know listening and reading and no
grammar then I think the concept of the
language class could change for the
better
and in fact what I'm intending to do is
sit up exactly that - I mean I don't I
don't pretend to be a language teacher
but I've learned a lot about language
acquisition in the last year and so what
I hope to do is speak with a native
speaker for a few minutes
so 20 minutes and then we have a cup of
coffee in a coffee shop and then the
second half involves telling people how
to acquire language efficiently and in a
nice entertaining fashion and then you
share the resources that you use found
you know these Spanish podcasts are good
and the pre content is very good but you
know be a bit wary about the paid
content because it's quite expensive and
that's the sort of thing I would hope to
do to improve the concept of the
language close I wonder if I could jump
in there mark a couple I see a couple of
questions that I'd like to respond to
first of all Giotto Slav Maxima has two
comments or questions here one is
whatever we think of studying several
languages at Primary School and then the
second thing grammar is necessary for
everyone so two comments on that first
of all I think it would be a good idea
to expose kids to more than one language
in primary school but that the emphasis
should be on comprehension on exposing
them to the language without any tests
without any comprehension questions
without worrying about what they
understand just let them get a sense of
two or three languages good for the
brain improves their call it receptivity
to different sounds different languages
have different sounds different
structures obviously if they had a
system like the link they could look up
words they would hear they would listen
to stories and not be tested on it and
if they did that for five or six years
through primary school exposing
themselves to two or three languages at
some point if they got very serious and
really wanted to learn one of those
languages they would be in great shape
to do so so I think it's a good idea to
expose kids to a lot of languages in
primary school
second of all grammar is necessary no I
don't believe that I don't believe that
deliberate grammar instruction is
effective what is necessary at some
point is to speak the language as
accurately as we can and are not
necessarily necessary but what most
people aspire to most people want to
speak with as few
mistakes as possible and in order to
speak with few mistakes we need to have
a lot of input in the language so that
our brain can get used to it and once we
have a lot of input and we are familiar
to some extent with the language only
then do the grammar explanations make
sense whereas if we try to learn grammar
rules and produce them correctly on a
test on Friday we will forget all of
those rules we won't be able to put them
into practice we won't be able to think
of the rules when we're trying to speak
whereas if we go through this process of
massive input we develop habits that
enable us to naturally speak more and
more correctly but never 100% correctly
so that's my comment on that one other
thing too I just looking at these
questions how to break out of the
intermediate level continue doing what
you're doing and how the best use of
tutors is to have a conversation
make sure the tutor gives you a report
ten fifth the way we do it link ten or
fifteen phrases that you didn't use
correctly and then you have that as a
conversation report and I was listening
to my converse and my tutors in Persian
and Arabic they record them and a
Turkish they record them so I can listen
to my conversation reports of them of a
year ago six months ago and go through
them I said link to listen to course
audio which I find extremely useful I
used to actually create my playlist now
I just go listen to course audio so I've
got 20 conversation reports one right
after the other and what I find is that
I make the same mistake every week
because the tutor is giving me the same
corrective phrase every week but that's
fine eventually you know I improve so
that I would recommend to get out of the
intermediate level continue doing what
you're doing vary the kind of content
you're listening to force yourself to
create 50 links of day so that you're
pushing yourself to new content and then
start talking to a tutor with the
objective that you're going to be
reviewing these conversation reports
both listening to them and reading them
from time to time just to vary your
activity in the language and you just
have to continue we have another
question is it possible to become fluent
and / near fluent from just using link
okay like if I can't tell you know
fluent implies speaking fluently in
order to speak fluently you have to
speak a lot so I think even if you use a
tutor at link you can't get enough
speaking time just talking to someone
you know twice or three times a week to
really become fluent so link is gonna
build you up in terms of your vocabulary
in terms of your listening comprehension
it's gonna create the potential and it's
gonna create habits in your brain
listening to many stories amongst other
things it's gonna build up the
capability so that if you then managed
to get into situations where you use the
language a lot maybe you have a circle
of friends where you live that speak the
language or you go to the country then
you can work towards fluency yeah I mean
if I look at my own case I think I speak
Russian well enough I speak with
mistakes I speak it well enough to be
interviewed on you know a Russian and
Ukrainian language television in Ukraine
when I was last there I have given talks
in Russian via Skype with mistakes and I
learned all of that on link but I
probably had maybe a hundred hours oh
and this is over a period of years this
is over a period of four five years but
I have read two million words in Russian
I have listened to I don't know how many
thousands of hours of Russian I've read
you know books and stuff like that so
it's possible it takes a long time but
ultimate and I was in Russia for 12 days
and I saw it spoke Russian while I was
there and I was in Ukraine for 12 days
and spoke Russian at least in the
eastern side of the country so I still
think you need to get that opportunity
to speak a lot and link builds you up to
a level where you can quickly work
towards fluency given the opportunity ok
there was a question a a few questions
on YouTube with someone's asking which
language is which language I'm studying
I'm currently studying Japanese before
that I was studying I guess Spanish and
before that Italian so trying to get my
Japanese level up trying to find that's
where I was having trouble with finding
finding books it just seems very
difficult in Japanese to find books for
some reason I read Harry Potter in
Japanese that's the only book I really
was able to find partly because their
books sir
they were eBook format seem to be
strange anyway
if anyone out there has recommendations
and where to find Japanese ebooks that
can be imported into interlink please
please let me know we had another
question about our upcoming update and
we haven't really talked much about our
update but someone's asking what's in
the update we are within I don't know
it's still probably a few months away
but we are working on a major update to
our library and to the reader just to
Laura
a big part of it is just a facelift you
have to upgrade the look and feel
regularly I think that's a common across
all platforms and but also obviously
improving on what's what's they're
trying to know I mean we get lots of
feedback all the time from from our
users and and we use it ourselves so so
yeah I mean I won't say much more than
that but hopefully that the very much
improving the ability to find the
content that that you're looking for and
manage the content that you're looking
for and and also making it easier to
find good content to import so so that's
a big part of what we're working on and
yeah my dad mark yeah I had I looked at
my Russian statistics and I started
working on Russian at Lincoln think in
2007 or 2008 so it's more than ten years
I've been at link for a long long time
and I am testing the new beta on the
mobile and I am very excited I'm like a
child with a new toy like it's the same
basic functionality but it's just much
more pleasant so I just throw that in
there for people I think you'll enjoy
what's what's being done but there's so
many different pieces that have to come
together it's all it's gonna take a
while yet
Oh in that question by the way that
question about becoming fluent I was
gonna ask you how many known words do
you have in Russian 90,000 so that just
kind of gives a bit of an indication to
people and and I know in Russian there
are more words so that your total's in
Russian tend to be higher than in other
languages but a lot of people just don't
realize how many known words you need to
get to like it doesn't have to be 90,000
I don't know what it has to be in
Russian but you know I mean I think you
often say and I would just like French
or Spanish it's 30,000 or some thirty
forty thousand navigate 40,000 so that's
a big thing for everybody to focus on it
takes time in it and that's why books as
we were as Paul was mentioning books are
so great because they're they really
drive vocabulary growth and and and not
just vocabulary growth but by by reading
and listening to that much in your
target language your comprehension
ability to parse the language understand
what people are saying understand what
you're reading just just goes up
exponentially uh no question about it
you know the fact that I have 90,000
words in Russian I don't know what that
means because there's so many different
forms of words in these Slavic languages
but it does mean that I have read and
listened a lot so it's kind of an
indicator that I mean I have read I
don't know two million words just on
link let alone books that I've read here
not on link and it just builds up that
comprehension last night on Netflix so
we briefly looked at a Russian movie my
wife and I which we didn't like but
Annie I can understand the movie okay I
understand it just as well as I
understand a French movie I my
comprehension in Russian
it's very good I speak I make more
mistakes in Russian than in French but I
have listened to so much Russian that my
comprehension is really very very good I
wanted to I could hear a couple of
questions that I see here you know what
do you read in which languages Steven
mark well you know it's it depends on
the language I got 20 languages I think
typically for me it's it's you know many
stories to get started then I look for
podcasts in the case of Persian I've got
a lady in Iran who has created a series
on the history of Iran which is sort of
at an intermediate level which I'm
really enjoying if it's a language like
polish going from Czech or Ukrainian I
can go straight to audiobooks and ebooks
because it's so similar to all this but
I also wanted to touch on the second
question how different is you're reading
from krashen's n plus-1 theory I don't
believe in the end plus one theory the
idea in the end plus one theory is you
should always you know be reading
material that has just a small number of
unknown words so to start with that's
impossible at the beginning because it's
only unknown words and as you priva ninh
the many stories it's it's there's gonna
be a lot of unknown words even though
there's so much repetition in the many
stories that as a percentage soon comes
down to a manageable level but going
forward if I was only gonna deal with
material that had a very small number of
new words in it I would take forever to
learn the language so I think this n
plus one works if you're reading a book
that you take off your bookshelf where
it's very frustrating to have a lot of
unknown words but if you're on link I
always consider a sweet spot to be like
10-15 percent
unknown words that's where I'm acquiring
word new words sufficiently quickly and
yet I'm not fighting an uphill battle
like thirty percent new words is just
too tough so I think a lot of the sort
of n plus-1 90% 95% known words always
applies to reading a book that you just
you know a paper book a true
once you're into an environment like
link necessarily you start off with a
hundred percent new words and then as to
the extent possible I try to aim it
towards about 15 percent unknown words
and yeah finish mark don't we have
finished there's a question about finish
don't we have finish to think yeah we
have finish yeah should be there in the
list of full list of languages you may
have to open the beta language list but
we have finished we have someone asking
how long it would take to reach c1 in
German considering as a native English
speaker and has already reached
proficiency in Irish for hours he's
asking if it would take four hours a day
or has he has four hours a day to study
well I mean if you take the example of
my Russian so here again I mean to me c1
implies you speak well so with link
you're gonna build up that potential
you should get to yourself to where you
can listen to you know authentic podcast
read German books build up your
vocabulary to 40 50 thousand words but
then you still have to go and find that
opportunity to speak a lot so I think
that how quickly can you get yourself to
fifty thousand known words in German and
I think you can do that four hours a day
in a year yes with a lot of dedication
and at some point there after three or
four months you're gonna want to speak a
lot you can do that either by a you know
tutor online or you can find friends but
c1 it implies you speak well so you got
to speak a lot to speak well so link can
build you up to that fifty thousand
known word level and then you're gonna
have to go out and find plenty of
opportunity to speak it's doable but
yeah I mean it's doable I I I think I
got to see one in Chinese in a year but
I was working seven hours a day at it so
but Chinese is a little more difficult
maybe
okay uh uh here's a question I'm
learning Spanish now but I also want to
learn Japanese so should I learn the
alphabet or can I just learn the
language without it yeah I think you
can't learn Japanese with Japanese okay
sorry I thought Spanish okay Jen Oh
Japanese yeah yeah yeah I think you have
to learn that if you actually you have
to be able to read to learn enough
vocabulary to really become proficient
and in order to read you have to learn
the the different scripts including the
kanji including the kanji but certainly
to start with you have to learn the
hiragana and and then from there you'll
pick up the kanji just by by doing
lessons and seeing the characters over
and over and the frequent words will
reappear and you'll start to learn them
but yeah the answer is at least you have
in my opinion you have each have to
learn the the script here mark is a
question when using link as a beginner
should I try reading the words verbally
when I lock them up or should I just
listen and keep going I think we
necessarily it doesn't really matter I
don't think it can be fun to pronounce
some of them it doesn't have to be all
or nothing you may want to pronounce
some of them to yourself you may not
want to I don't think it matters much
but you say or should I just keep going
I think the main thing is to keep going
so if you're in the mini stories which I
recommend as a beginner then don't just
wait until you've totally eights the
first story or any content that you're
on don't don't try to sort of totally
master anything expose yourself to the
language so keep going keep going keep
going but with the individual words that
you look up yeah I mean maybe you want
to look up the conjugation table for fun
or maybe you want to pronounce it you
know the dahle a bit and savor that word
a little bit and you may do it
differently with different words I don't
think it matters much the main thing is
to force yourself to get into more and
more content to listen
to more and more content then double
back and read again listen again when
you're bored of doing that charge
forward into new material
just keep exposed bombarding your brain
with the language I have a question here
about to using tags and so I thought
maybe it'd be worth actually
demonstrating this because I think tags
are something that a lot of people don't
use the question the question was how
can we use tags on vocabulary
effectively for Russian I see everyone
want to explore conjugations I can see a
tag for infinitive anyway I think just
in terms of explaining the tags for
those of you who don't use them you'll
see that hid this is Italian here's a
verb in Italian here's to here are some
tags that are generated automatically
for every every verb and in Italian in a
lot of languages not all languages but a
lot of languages have these automatic
tags and so the tag will tell you that
it's a verb there's a tag that tells you
it's a verb it'll tell you the person of
this verb form if there is one it'll
tell you the tense of the verb and then
the root forms of the verb that this
could possibly be from the tags are
clickable so if I click on this verb tag
it will take me to our grammar guide
which is probably worth knowing the
grammar guide is available again in a
lot of languages and we'll explain we'll
talk about verbs in this language there
are lots of other obviously things
containing those grammar guys are great
sort of simple grammar resources that
you can refer to when you have grammar
questions so up just to point that out
to people the tense will also take you
back to the grammar guide and explained
that tense and then if you click on the
root form of the verb it'll actually
open up a conjugation table for that
verb so those are actually important
little hints
our tools to become familiar with
especially in languages where you might
be having trouble with the verb forms
and so far as you don't utilizing tags
these tags are automatic I can also add
manual tags so I mean I could say that
you know I have a list that they say I
really want to learn this word you know
key vocab or something I can I can label
it with whatever tag I want I can then
in terms of reviewing I can go to the
vocabulary page and then I can click
this filter and then I can it suggests a
few tags here but I can I can find this
tag that I just created and see this see
whatever words I have obviously for that
tag which I can then review and this is
how we kind of recommend using review we
kind of don't recommend using review for
all the links that you create since you
should be creating far too many links
than you can possibly review but if
there are specific lists of words or
maybe verb tenses you know if you have
problems with the Italian conjunct to
you anyway was it conjoint you're
looking for subjunctive oh yeah right
conjunct to you so so now all of a
sudden I get a list of all my
subjunctive forms of the verb in Italian
and then I can click to review that list
so that if I'm having problems with that
form it's kind of a handy way to review
that's how we recommend using them
review but obviously again we always say
it's up to you you should do what you
like doing if you like review I mean it
especially when you start to review all
the
your links per page as you're working
through a lesson is also a good way to
go
especially if you like doing it and it
can help you get a toehold in the
language I don't know if you have some
thoughts there yeah I would just add
that you know the person I think the
question had to do with Russian and I
use the tags a lot in Russian for their
case endings like there are some things
in Russian that don't exist in English
like they're verbs of motion their
aspect to verbs and their cases some
cases are harder to remember than others
so I even tagged them for the case
sometimes incorrectly I got the wrong
case but the point is that we learn from
examples and if we can get concentrated
examples of something that we can review
that kind of socks it in in a way better
than a lot of explanation so tags are
very good to give yourself a
concentrated list of examples of some
form that you have trouble with so I use
them a lot in Russian still make
mistakes by the way another question
when defining blue words and link do you
look for specific conjugations or just
the basic definition at least in terms
of for myself and I think what you're
asking is do you do I define the root
form or do I actually define the form of
the word that I'm looking at and I I
prefer to define the exact form of the
word that I'm looking at I just find
that's the definition of that word and
so that's what I like to see and that's
what I like to add but I guess then it's
it's personal preference if you would
rather see the root form you can but I
find that the root form you'll come
across eventually and you put that
definite definition in for the root form
but to have the actual definition of
that specific instance is helpful for me
yeah I agree with you I tend where
possible I want to form of that the
translation to conform to whatever that
word is doing in a particular context
but it's not always possible I tend
move quickly if there's a hint available
that's just the root form I just take
that the infinitive or whatever so you
know but where possible I like to have
it conform to whatever the function of
the word is in that sentence I also
wanted to answer there was a question
here I'll go study at a severe quanto
tempo putt for D attend UK's to that
English how many hours a day do I have
to study English
Puma Ora like to me it's one hour if
you're doing less than one hour
you're not gonna achieve much and that's
easily done forty-five minutes of
listening call it an hour an hour and 15
minutes so 45 minutes of listening
wherever you are working out in the car
in the bus whatever and then another
half an hour you know saving words and
stuff like that so puma ora cuenta Cinco
minutos escuchando a Kenzi 20 minutos
trabajando con le o link that's my
answer there you should be able to get
in an hour and 15 minutes a day duolingo
a good app to learn languages was
another one again I haven't had much
experience with duolingo I got in there
and there were a lot of strange
sentences about the dog ate the snake
and stuff like that so I didn't find it
all that helpful but a lot of people
used it a lot of people liked it it's
something you can do you can do it in
conjunction with link or if you like
doing it and you continue doing it it's
it's all good exposure to the language
it's good but I don't have enough
experience to say you know I don't think
it takes you as far as Marc said earlier
the advantage with link is that however
you get yourself going in the language
at some point you have to get to real
stuff audio book ebook movies newspaper
articles and I think that's where the
limits of duolingo are and I think
they'll tell you as much I mean they
don't they actually have said they don't
claim to teach you a language they I
mean to get you to fluency they it's
it's something to get you started it's
kind of fun it's better than playing
video games developing your skills I had
a question here oh i'm brazilian i have
23,000
own words in English and 27000 non words
in Spanish when could I start to speak
how many hours should I speak per week I
mean you just start to speak I think I
once I have 10,000 words if I have the
time I like to speak it's fun to try it
out it provides more variety and it
gives you a sense of where your problems
are is it's fun to connect with a native
speaker even three I used to wait longer
with rush and I waited a long time if
you want to speak speak you certainly
have enough words to speak and yeah yeah
let's see what else we have this one
here does listening to podcasts over and
over without understanding help
assimilating the language not much maybe
some but not very much I always want to
be able to read what I'm listening to if
I understand essentially nothing I don't
think I'm doing much I mean it's not
like it's zero but it's rather an
ineffective use of time Steve as an
English teacher what would you recommend
I do to teach effectively grammar
instruction and immediate feedback is
expected by the school the students
themselves it's a problem I mean if I
were English teacher I have a curriculum
I have a school director they expect
certain things tests results and so
forth I would try to persuade my
students that they're going to achieve
better results on any test if they do a
lot of listening and reading I would
encourage them to read more and listen
more and if they have questions about
grammar we can discuss those in class
and if we can discuss I mean if these
two people are learning English that we
can discuss it in English that's good
for them they won't necessarily remember
the explanations but if the whole thing
is in English that's good and I would
just encourage them that you know in
order if they're motivated to learn they
have to get to where they are consuming
a lot of the language so you know
maintain whatever the requirements of
the curriculum are but try to encourage
them to do a lot of
listening and reading get them on link
I'm two months into Russian with great
success I talked to a lot of people but
it's difficult learning when I talk to
them as soon as I don't know the words I
can't keep the conversation and without
switching to English it's hard to have
an interesting conversation what do you
suggest to do keep talking about the
same things over and over or switch to
English to ask for help well my
suggestion is that you want to have far
more input activities than online
discussions very frustrating and I tried
it in Korean at an early stage if you
don't understand what the person is
saying and you have a very limited
vocabulary you're always talking about
where they live is it raining it's it's
not very satisfying the other thing that
I found useful when I had real trouble
speaking at an early stage let's say in
Arabic because I had trouble reading
then I would read with my teacher
because I wasn't confident that when I
was reading in Arabic that I was
pronouncing the words correctly or in
Persian because the writing system it's
not a it's not a one-to-one it's not
like Spanish where you pronounce it like
you're reading so if you're at a level
in Russian where you're still because
the Cyrillic alphabet is not as
difficult as the Arabic alphabet but
it's always difficult to read in another
alphabet so one thing if you want to
have that interaction with the tutor
again I would go to the many stories get
the many stories read the many stories
on you know during your conversation
with the tutor and then have a bunch of
questions and answers with your tutor on
the content of that mini story because
the mini story already has a bunch of
questions in there so you know you're
kind of you got some momentum and that
will build up your confidence
I think the many stories are great sort
of base content to bring into a
conversation when you are at a very
early stage in the language which is the
next language to be added to link I
can't really remember now what is next
waiting basically add languages if we
are provided if we have volunteers
provide us with 60 mini stories
but I can't we do have some that are
waiting to be put up probably won't be
put up until after we've launched our
diversion I can't honestly remember what
they are right now so it was a tire
Georgia or Georgian was was another one
yeah anyway Giotto Slav struggle with
German deer like how it sounds I like
all the languages and are we son and
father yes I find that the languages
sound better the more you understand
them and don't understand a language it
can sound quite you I find that's when
you find you don't enjoy the particular
language and the more you understand the
more you enjoy it there's always a
resistance to a new language because
it's hard and it sounds strange and
stuff and as you get into it more say
with German where they have these
somewhat convoluted sentences after a
while you get more and more comfortable
with this it's actually fun and it's
enjoyable I find that with every
language once you get into it it becomes
more and more enjoyable that ease for me
what word cow do you recommend on link
before outputting in Chinese well since
I haven't learned Chinese like I haven't
studied on link but I think that five
thousand to ten thousand is a level
where you can at least start talking to
people and then it's gonna be it's a
matter of how do you want to spend your
time and your money so I think it's
personal I don't think there's any hard
and fast rule how do you go about
learning a script if you were to start
hindi tomorrow how would you go about it
well I have the most the most recent so
recently of course Cyrillic going back
to my first exposure to Russian and then
Korean Hangul and then Greek and then of
course Ukrainian which is slightly
different from Russian but essentially
the same and and most recently with
Arabic and Persian so let's start with
Arabic and Persian you've got
four forms of each letter depending on
whether it's on its own or at the
beginning or the middle or the end of a
word very difficult changes form doesn't
necessarily get pronounced the same way
it might be wah-wah very difficult the
thing is it just takes time so you you
study these letters what they mean you
keep on getting them wrong you think
it's this letter but it's some other
letter you read more it's just a gradual
process of listening and reading a lot
of listening and reading at the same
time
the Arabic text to speech is very
helpful unfortunately we don't have
text-to-speech in Persian but if you're
getting used to a new script where we
have text-to-speech like if it's
Cyrillic use the text-to-speech and it's
just the brain will gradually get better
at it it's not gonna get worse so you
just have to keep going I studied
Spanish in college and I'm growing bored
with Spanish but I recognize the utility
my heart wants to learn Chinese how do
you know when to move on to the next
language when your heart wants to move
on move on your Spanish will only
improve when you go back to it when you
first start a new language do you use
subtitles when watching movies is it
best to use target subtitles or English
ones I mean when I started into Russian
I watched movies with English subtitles
because I was enjoying the movie and the
movie was stimulating to me but I wasn't
learning Russian if you want to use
movies for learning the language you
need subtitles in the language you're
learning and you know if it's on YouTube
I think or Netflix you can import that
dialogue those subtitles into link and
learn those words but I think watching
with English subtitles I mean it helps
to the extent that you understand some
but it's not a not something that I do
to learn the language but it's yeah
sometimes it helps you understand what
you're hearing you would have missed it
otherwise but because the subtitle is
there in English you kind of pick up on
what you heard but I prefer to watch
with
sometimes in the target language in the
does this though subtitles and target
language do the same they help you
understand much better than with just
listening alone but at least it's in
your target language and not like I
found for example when I was going
through Netflix and there is this app
called learning with Netflix where they
gave and it was difficult because they
spoke Egyptian Arabic they had the
subtitles in Standard Arabic and they
also had English translation but I never
I found after a while I didn't look at
the English translation I looked at the
Standard Arabic which was still
different from the spoken Arabic but
it's because another opportunity to read
in that language like you gotta get to
reading reading is so important so even
reading subtitles in the language is
training your brain to read that
language which I think is very important
ultimately you have to read a lot I'm
studying Spanish and sometimes complex
sentences have features like verbs in
both the predator right and imperfect
are too long to fit in a single link any
workarounds for verbs so in the same
sentence some were verbs will be in the
preterite and some will be in the
imperfect yeah that happens in English
but I don't understand the question that
features are too long to fit in a single
link
I don't you mean you're trying to save a
phrase that's too long
I assume you're trying to save both
forms of the word and the same phrase
maybe in anyway we limit the length of
phrases we we don't want you saving
senses or long chunks because it has a
number of unintended consequences in the
in the rest of the system so yeah I
saved to smaller chunks I think if
that's the issue that you're having and
this is an issue that comes with regard
to separable verbs in German and it's
just not that be easy to save huge
segments sections of text so we don't
we don't allow it if you want to
translate a whole sentence their
sentence view for that but you shouldn't
be saving full sentences the idea is you
want to save words and shorter phrases
as chunks that you can learn and learn
to use so we there's no real reason to
save long passages because you're not
likely to reuse long passages of text as
much Paul you were gonna comment on that
I was gonna say like yeah I think what
what is folks I've had it before well if
I cut a really long sentence I've wanted
to translate in it like highlight when
it goes so far and you've got to try
like break it off but sometimes the like
the word change is dependent on like
what how it's used and like sometimes
you little click off of it you know
let's say like the one translation but
really and you do that one once half the
sentence is in that makes sense I'm not
sure yeah I don't I I share a Marx view
I find that I want to say fresh shorter
phrases because shorter phrases are
gonna repeat shorter phrases can be
tagged are useful to use it's handy to
have phrases that you can trot out that
you don't have to make everything up
word-for-word you have these
prefabricated little phrases you can use
whereas sentences tend to be more
individual like each sentence long
sentence like they don't repeat that
often the sentences tend to be unique
far more than phrases so I focus on
saving phrases that eventually I want to
be able to use and that might reoccur in
future lessons and so on
do you a Paul do you use the sentence
view when you're studying or the full
page I use the flow page I find it
easier with the Ojo because I'm using
just I kind of read develop it as
opposed I'm gonna click on it to the
next page
yeah yeah I tend to sort of flip back
and forth I use the sentence view if I
don't understand the sentence then I'll
flip to sentence view to get a
translation and see what what the
sentence translation tells me just as
another potential clue or
way to
understand what I'm what I'm reading I
find the sentence view in week the
languages where I'm not very strong like
Arabic and Persian I much prefer to be
incentive to you if I'm strong in the
language then I can stay in paid if you
I also wanted to if I could mark there
was a question here which I think is a
really good one from John how do you get
back your motivation during a slump so
yeah I mean language learning
unfortunately progress is very slow
maybe in the initial few months we have
this sense of all of a sudden we
understand something all of a sudden we
can say a few things where before we
started we knew nothing and then we hit
somebody described it the other day as
the desert crossing the desert I was
talking sober to a podcaster and this is
a doldrums this is that long long long
period where word frequency has dropped
so we're not encountering these words as
often as we did in the first say
thousand words where they come up all
the time we don't really have the
impression we're getting much better
we're struggling with content that's
difficult we don't understand and so
it's easy to get demotivated so what do
you do when you're demotivated well some
of the things that I do we talked about
like Chris talked about is 50 links a
day gold so if you have a mechanical
goal you have to create 50 links so
whether you like it or not you got to
get into some new content where there's
some you know enough blue words that you
can at least get your 50 links so even
if you have the impression that you
aren't getting any better at least you
saved 50 links so you did something and
we know that if you are active in the
language you will get better you may not
think you're getting better but you will
get better and every so often I look at
my page in Arabic and I still don't
understand when they're talking but look
at my page it's mostly white there's
some yellow and there's some blue
whereas it used to be covered in blue so
I remind myself that I've improved so I
think it's important to give yourself
credit for what you have achieved so you
know do some things that mechanically
force you to do something give yourself
credit for what you've achieved or take
a rest you know if you're really not
motivated the other thing you can do is
vary the kind of stuff you're listening
to maybe your motivation is
slumping because you're doing too much
repetitious you know work with the
mini-stories so then go off and find
yourself some interesting content maybe
your demotivated because the interesting
content is too difficult go back to the
many stories or look for some
intermediate content very our activity
go and review your words and flashcards
even though that's not something that I
do a lot of when my motivation kind of
drops
I want to vary my activity then I'll do
that or maybe I'll get an online tutor
and have a few sessions so that I think
varying your activity can help recharge
your motivation or in some cases go and
learn another language and then when you
come back to that first language
you'll be refreshed you won't feel as if
you're sort of you know fighting this
uphill battle without any results so
those are some of the things that I
would recommend to get your motivation
back yeah I want to learn Chinese and
bought living language Mandarin Chinese
to get a basic vocab but since it feels
difficult to start with no vocabulary on
link is that a good strategy you know I
bought all of those living language I I
find it I find them difficult so link
has the following advantage you can
click on a word and immediately see the
meaning you can save that word your page
is interactive you're seeing your
progress fewer and fewer blue words
you've got you know you such a variety
of content to listen to you've got audio
and text for everything a lot of these
programs like living language they have
a lot of English in their audio which I
can't listen to more than once so it's
it's another way of covering the
material it provides more explanation of
how the language works and the structure
and that kind of thing which can be
useful to have I think it's a good thing
I mean I typically I don't go for I
might have used living language I tend
to go to teach yourself I tend to have
another little book because again
variety covering the same material in
different ways it's a good thing so I
have my little book might be teacher
self
I might have it by my bedside I flipped
through the glaad then at other times in
the day I'm listening to Linc
I might even listen to the teacher self
thing even though I get annoyed and
having to listen to the English you know
explanation you know in the following
chapter John and Mary visit their
friends Meili and Jing Chang and we
don't need that after a while you know
so yeah it's part of the strategy keeps
things varied and stuff sure at a higher
level do you think reading books novels
should be done freely ie not looking up
unknown words as you go my thing is if I
pick up a book like a paper book I don't
look up anything if I'm on link I look
up everything that's just how I do it
and reading away from the computer
reading a book which is not so easy for
me to do in Arabic but certainly in
Polish I can take a book that's got 10%
unknown words and it's still enjoyable
to read it as a book and I don't look up
anything whereas if I'm looking even if
I'm reviewing a mini story in Polish and
there's a word I forgotten I'll look it
up okay what but if and maybe we'll end
on this question here how can one become
capable of writing in a foreign language
we haven't spoken about writing today
what should be your the journey for this
skill development in your opinion well
you got to write so we have the ability
on link you can post your writing and
people will correct it on our what's it
called exchange write we have a writing
exchange and and then it depends how
serious you are about your writing I
mean if you are really concerned about
writing you could submit writing to
tutors and and pay them to correct it
and comment on it and analyze it in more
depth so we also if you're at an early
stage like for example for me to write
in Arabic or even in Greek is very
difficult but I can save phrases and
then use the dictation function when I
review these phrases and that then
forces me to write those so I can begin
by learning to write because the content
writing system is
so difficult for me the alphabet so at
least I developed some initial
capability to even write anything in the
language and thereafter
I might compose something I might have a
diary like a lot of people keep Diaries
or I might translate from maybe take a
larger chunk of text and translate it
into the target language and maybe
submit it you know I find that initially
to actually have to compose something is
maybe more difficult if you just
translate something then you don't have
to worry about what you're gonna write
you just have to translate it and then
you can submit that either to a tutor to
have it formally corrected or on our
exchange to have volunteers correct but
it is a great thing to do there's no
question and the writing exchange is
very popular and usually get lots of
great feedback there and that's entirely
free on the community on the web app you
do have to be on the web um okay well
with that we'll wrap it up for today
thanks very much Paul and Chris for
joining us on sharing your story and
yeah we look forward to doing this again
next week in the meantime everybody have
a have a good week stay safe and they
say if he happy linking Happy Easter -
yeah Happy Easter
okay bye-bye bye-bye